the homepage of your phone right take  your phone out everybody at home ran out  take your phone out take your phone out  and look what's on your phone there's  only three things on your phone escapism  and entertainment information and  utility and social people so you have  Facebook and Twitter and it's that stuff  you have utility your calendar Evernote  your to-do list and have entertainment  some games and music nobody has anything  else on the homepage of their phone the  home screen and by the way the home  screen of a telephone today in our  society is the biggest gateway to the  psychology of human beings on earth  so the way